[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best because we simply
said so that is how this works the show
that my brothers and i wish that we had
we're learning about business investing
and finance i'm here with two my
brothers joe and john how do you know
their names are joe and john real simple
they keep their heads down and play on
their computers the entire show no just
kidding their names are on the back of
their chairs
we have a big big show for you today we
have everything from peter schiff lynn
alden coming on the show one back to
back they are going to be talking about
everything from inflation to
macroeconomics to all sorts of
employment information this is going to
be a show that you do not want to miss
go tell your friends to get on in here
on top of that we have a bunch of things
to go over before we get to that we have
some housekeeping items the first
housekeeping ice item is the following
you know how this works the content's
free when the content is free all you
got to do is you got to come in you got
to press the like button when you press
like button that means more people on
youtube will see it more people who see
it the more people get educated the
better the world is so quite literally
you pressing the like button makes the
world a better place on top of that
we're going to give out all kinds of
bitcoin today every 500 likes we're
going to be firing off
199
worth of bitcoin that's right 199
of bitcoin every single time we cross
over 500 likes 200 bucks let's get it
peter schiff and lynn alden aren't
coming here for a small show
one two three press the like button
wants to cross over 500 john will pick a
winner and we'll get after it you good
there he is there he is he's smiling
everyone was saying joe looks real
intense right now joe's not paying
attention
in the chat no one was saying that
you're making up nonsense i'm here i'm
good i'm chilling with my boy john we're
feeling good how you doing john i'm
great how are you good john's always
good john also says saying pay me a
bitcoin right now you mean bitcoin
uh on top of that if you want go to the
merch store now here's the deal with the
merch i i now officially have the
ability to i don't know i got a [ __ ]
microphone today i got to get this this
bad boy up here i was standing there
yesterday
i'm a rat on myself i stand there i
lowered the mic a little bit i ain't
going to say nothing but your voice back
you had your shoes on you know me i
ain't got no shoes on i hear you all
right
i am now allowed to talk about this so
what is it in two weeks
is black friday and then cyber monday
we have an absolute bonanza sale i don't
know if that's the right terminology but
we have massive massive sale that we are
going to go ahead and we are going to uh
play on thebestbusinessshow.com
we have some things in store we're going
to do all kinds of giveaways we're going
to do a whole little show around it etc
but if you are ready
on black friday and cyber monday the
best place in the world to get your
christmas gifts is going to be here in
this store we got all kinds of new stuff
that we're going to be releasing et
cetera so make sure that you get back
here to look at it lastly so five
sofa.com
the diamond hands club john what was
your general take on the diamond heads
club i loved it you loved it yeah i
think people came with some really good
questions i think that they had a
general understanding of where they were
personally and then they got to utilize
both sofi if they had any questions
about the product and then also the
financial advisor who joined us i think
was really informative on a bunch of
different um tax stuff and 401ks and and
all the stuff that people really care
about but no one ever talks about
it um
it also feels like not only can people
answer get their questions answered but
uh there's this
maybe safety i don't know like this
peace of mind that you can show up and
you can ask the questions like
it's no secret i'm not a big fan of
financial advisors it's not something
that i think most people uh actually
need i think that you should go learn
yourself we'll talk about a little bit
later in the show so brian isn't
no but here's my thing is that there's a
different relationship when you're
paying somebody to do it for you and and
there's like an extractive relationship
versus if i have access to one they do
have good information and uh the guy
brian who is the financial advisor from
so far who came on i thought he was uh
one very very knowledgeable and two he
was like super chilly he was just like
hey listen i i'm not your specific one
but i can answer questions about how
this stuff works i thought it was very
good and i could see that if you're
going to use a financial advisor for
information it's always better to like
ask one who has the knowledge but you
don't feel like there's an extractive
relationship between you and the
financial advisor right yeah so we'll
get to all that in a little bit but go
to sofi.com thousand dollars in an
account and you will be in the diamond
hands club that's how that works you
guys ready i'm ready we we got some uh
we got a lot to go over today
breaking news the city of miami is now
going to be paying citizens bitcoin
dividends what yes the news just came
out literally about 17 minutes ago
everyone knows that el salvador has been
paying citizens to go ahead and download
the chivo wallet the chivo wallet allows
you to interact with the bitcoin network
the lightning network et cetera you can
send you can receive you can hold
bitcoin with that chiva wallet el
salvador pays their citizens 30 in
bitcoin to go ahead and get that chiva
wallet think of this as a fee or a
reward for downloading the app but the
city of miami just announced that they
are going to be paying yield
via
something called the miami coin now
before we get into the details of how
this actually works one thing is very
important is that the bitcoin layer one
is exactly that it is a layer one there
are going to be layer twos built on top
of it many of you are probably familiar
with the lightning network being one of
those there is a second layer two that
is on top of the bitcoin network called
stacks stacks is bringing smart contract
functionality to the bitcoin network i'm
not going to go into super detail in
terms of how they leverage the layer one
for security but the idea of layer twos
and layer ones is that the layer one is
super decentralized it's the most
decentralized blockchain in the world it
is also very very secure the layer one
makes specific trade-offs between having
high security and it doesn't worry about
does it have the fastest throughput or
the cheapest fees it's simply the same
we are the most decentralized in the
world and we are going to be the most
secure the idea then is that we will
build layer twos to go ahead and scale
the lightning network again being the
best example of a layer two where you
can whip any amount of bitcoin anywhere
in the world instantaneous nearly for
free and you can do that leveraging the
security of the layer one now stacks is
bringing the smart contract
functionality to bitcoin and on top of
stacks there is something called city
coins miami was the first one to go
ahead and participate in this the way
that it works in a very generalized way
is that there is a city coin that ends
up being mined by the citizens those
citizens are
everyday people who go and they hold
this asset and when they hold the asset
they have the ability to earn yield that
yield can come in a couple of different
forms but one of the key details of this
is that there is a wallet set aside for
the local city so for miami the city of
miami there was a wallet set aside and
they get a percentage of what is mined
on every single block and so as that
money has gone in there it started out
there was five million dollars in the
wallet for the city six million seven
million eight million nine million ten
million it's all the way up now to over
20 million dollars now why is this
important because the city doesn't own
the wallet to start with it's just
sitting there it's reserved for them but
they have to go claim the wallet they
have to say yes we would like that money
we would like to participate in this
program and so the city of miami came
together they had a meeting they decided
yes we want the wallet they went ahead
and they are claiming the wallet so
there was a decision that was made now
what they are talking about here is that
the city's mayor francis suarez just
announced today that they are going to
go ahead and they are going to pay out
yield from this entire thing and so if
we go ahead and we look at how they are
doing this right he says we are going to
be the first city in america to give a
bitcoin yield as a dividend directly to
its residents hold on a second a bitcoin
yield as a dividend directly to the
citizens quite literally if you are a
citizen of miami you have a digital
wallet you now are going to be eligible
for this bitcoin yield as a dividend now
what exactly does that mean in terms of
how this works the yield comes from the
staking of the city's own cryptocurrency
miami coin it's introduced earlier this
year and has already earned over 21
million dollars in the past three months
it's coming from a coindesk article and
he noted that if you were to annualize
that revenue it would equal roughly
one-fifth of miami's total annual tax
revenue of 400 million dollars now the
payment is going to be done through
digital wallets but for which the city
will work with a variety of different
people it's going to be across all the
different platforms that you will be
able to participate and so what this
ends up looking like if you listen to uh
patrick stanley who's one of the people
who's very involved in this he said that
mayor suarez just turned his city into
an oil producing country that gives
bitcoin yield to its citizens so very
similar to any sort of country that has
a very big oil deposit and they're able
to actually extract that and sell it and
generate yield then participate or have
that sent to some of their citizens
miami is now doing something very
similar and so when you go ahead and you
see this
you got to ask yourself is this going to
be the revolution for how city
governments fund themselves because
400 million dollars is the annual tax
revenue for the city of miami 400
million dollars and if you go ahead and
you actually annualize what they're
receiving from this system today that
will be the equivalent of about
one-fifth of their total annual tax
revenue so you look at that two
different ways that could increase their
tax revenue or or the base of capital
that they have by 20
or maybe they could actually drop the
taxes that citizens need to pay in order
to be compensated by this new system
it's very very interesting and so not
only is this happening in miami of
course we know that the new new york
city mayor eric adams coming out hot
saying i'm not going to take one
paycheck in bitcoin i'm going to take
three paychecks in bitcoin trying to
establish new york trying to catch up to
new uh trying to catch up to miami and
so now we have two mayors in the united
states that both run major cities who
are competing to see who can be more
bitcoin friendly is eric adams going to
be able to catch francis suarez well as
we know fast followers they can follow
fast but one of the problems is that if
you aren't a true innovator then you're
always one step behind now what new york
is doing is they have gone ahead and
they have indicated that they are going
to participate in the nyc coin so now we
have not only miami doing this but we
also have new york city and so if you
can see a world where there's a massive
amount of revenue that is generated for
the city of new york it works for miami
it works for new york in my opinion i
could see this happening all over the
country and again it's all tied back to
the layer one security of the bitcoin
blockchain now there are tons of
critiques of the system there are tons
of people who disagree with the way that
it's being built there's tons of people
who see risks in it and so what i
continue to tell everyone is this is one
of those things where you should really
go learn about it right how exactly it
works is important to understand why
this is interesting to the cities is
really important there's incredible
kind of chaos and uncertainty and
breakage when it comes to a lot of
what's happening with the city budgets
and the way that they're funded and then
on top of it there is still all sorts of
risks and so i always look at these
things and i say i'm cautiously
optimistic if we can figure out a way to
actually leverage this technology to
create more revenue for a city then that
would be very very interesting so when
you guys see this news what is kind of
your take on the idea of one cities
being able to actually get some of this
revenue and potentially have an impact
on how much tax revenue they need from
the citizens but then two the mayor's
saying oh by the way i'm gonna start
shelling out bitcoin uh yield as
dividends to our citizens i think it's
crazy
i mean it's crazy but awesome right i
think uh the quote that he said was it
could eventually eliminate the need for
residents to pay taxes right literally
just think about that for a second
eliminate the need for people to pay
taxes in the city of miami that's wild
that's a that's a crazy thought to think
about that something can have that kind
of impact but on a bigger more broad
scale i think it's interesting to see
the competition that's going to heat up
right we're talking about eric adams
mayor eric adams in new york city new
york city is is the largest city in the
world there's over 8 million people
there miami is just is a is a big city
also 500 000 people or so here top 50
city in the country i think what we're
going to find is all these cities are
going to start competing against each
other to see who can become the most
bitcoin friendly and i think it starts
with new york obviously the biggest city
in the country miami has been doing this
for at least a year now to two years uh
with mayor suarez and then we're gonna
see a bunch of others does chicago get
involved does la get involved what other
major cities start competing not only to
attract people but to retain the people
that are already there right because i
think as bitcoin comes uh becomes more
mainstream is adopted more by more
people and everyone starts to realize
how necessary some of this stuff is
they're going to demand it out of their
politicians and their local leaders that
they start doing things like this so i
think it's going to be fascinating to
watch uh and it's cool to see miami the
city that we live in currently being one
of the first people to adopt this it's a
community-centric way to earn revenue
for the city but not paying taxes is
insane if that ever happens to miami i'm
never leaving
why not paying taxes in uh in miami to
the city would be wild getting yield on
something that you own within the city
is wild it is clearly that is clear that
miami is becoming not only a crypto hub
but a hub for innovation in general
around every aspect
um new york and miami they're competing
right now right eric adams has seen what
mayor schwartz has done in miami and he
has continuously tried to implement the
same exact things because he sees that
they are working um this is gonna be a
great competition and like joe said
we're gonna see i think we're going to
see more cities do this in the future um
whether it's this specific project or
anything that miami has done on the
crypto front i think more cities have to
get involved or they're going to
seriously lag behind and they may lose
citizens because of it right people want
to be where the innovation is
the part that i also think is very
fascinating about this is uh every
single city every single politician
every single government uh around the
world continues to try to increase taxes
continues to try to um
extract value from their citizens right
and now what we're seeing is we're
literally seeing the use of new
technology to generate yield uh and to
generate a return for the city and one
of the things that i always go back to
that i think is really important is that
there's always been a zero-sum
relationship between the citizens and a
city or citizens and a government it's
the either you get to keep the money or
i as the government get to take it from
you and so that zero-sum mentality
between citizens and politicians i think
is now uh there's a third path right it
doesn't have to be the citizens wins or
the politician wins now the third path
is a positive sum game where it was
something like this somebody can say
wait a second here i can actually get a
yield from the same system that the
government does so i have an opportunity
to gain just at the same rate that the
government has an opportunity to gain
and again these are new systems and so i
don't want to say that it's all figured
out i don't want to present it as if uh
it's just like hey everything's going up
and to the right and you know it's going
to be this like tech utopia but what i
do think is that the most uh kind of
fascinating part that does not get
talked about enough is that there is
nobody talking about that zero sum to
positive some mindset and there's plenty
of people who don't like this or think
it's stupid or they think somehow the
citizens are gonna get screwed or
whatever
but when you look at it and you start to
understand how this system works i think
every single city in america is going to
do this well it's new innovation right
innovation has to be watched carefully
um because it's never been done before
something like this right so as it kind
of progresses i think we'll see more and
more um either scrutiny or pro for it
and then people will kind of choose
their side whether they like it or not
but i'm a big fan of miami coin and what
they're doing true the second people
realize that their city is giving them
bitcoin instead of them just paying
taxes they're gonna they're gonna lose
their their uh their [ __ ]
right i mean think about it it's
literally what they're saying again we
need all the details of exactly how it's
going to work what is the uh percent
return if you get just a couple of
satoshi's people like hey i like the
idea but like it's not worth moving
there's no kind of true economic uh
thing but if all of a sudden they said
to somebody you know what you're gonna
do is uh you quite literally are going
to be able to uh uh move here open a
digital wallet when you open a digital
wallet what you're gonna get is uh let's
say um a hundred dollars a month just a
hundred dollars a month and you
literally do that simply for being here
and by the way what we do is we uh put
it in your digital wallet and when you
have to pay taxes if the price of uh
bitcoin continues to go up then you can
almost just give us back the bitcoin
that becomes pretty interesting and
again so we got to see how this all
plays out but
again
did anybody have in their 2021 bingo
card that a city in the united states
won a politician was gonna get paid in
bitcoin i don't think anyone thought
that was gonna happen
now we have four mayors in the united
states that are all going to take uh
bitcoin as part of their salary the
second thing is i don't think anyone
thought that there was going to be a
city that was going to actually generate
meaningful revenue for their city using
uh these types of technologies right and
so we see that happening but then the
second thing is i don't think anyone
thought that there was a possibility in
2021 that a city was going to pay their
citizens bitcoin yield i don't think
anyone thought that was in the cards
right nobody thought that el salvador
was going to do anything and definitely
i don't think anyone thought a u.s city
was going to do it you know what's
interesting too in my opinion is that uh
miami is a is a large city obviously
it's a well-known city
and all of that but it's not the biggest
city in the country right it's the 44th
largest city in this country how many
other politicians and and whether state
local whatever how many politicians were
approached with similar things and turn
them down right i think one of the
biggest benefits that uh mayor suarez
probably doesn't even get enough credit
for is he's just open-minded right and
he's saying hey look i'm gonna look into
this technology i'm gonna go see what we
can do with this and look what it's
translated into they're gonna end up
paying citizens in bitcoin and whether
it's a dollar a hundred dollars a
thousand dollars whatever it ends up
being i think he deserves a lot of
credit for being really open-minded and
not only being open-minded but actually
doing the work and going to look at all
these technologies because as we've seen
there's 45 other cities that are bigger
than his that would have gotten these
offers also that didn't go and make the
same moves
there's a ton of people oh they
continued to go to all these different
cities and what i love about this is
they're going city by city by city and
the cities have to opt in isn't just hey
here's the free money it sits there like
a carrot you want to play you want to
participate you think that you actually
are ready for this are you innovative
enough are you technology savvy enough
are you actually in need of the money
claim the wallet
if you don't that's okay then you don't
have to participate at all
whatever we say is going to do economic
incentives are powerful man every every
single city is going to go in and
they're going to go ahead and they're
going to claim it right and i think that
that is how it works we have munib from
stax he just tweeted this he said miami
a city of miami will give residents
bitcoin wallets and pay them in bitcoin
using their treasury yield powered by
stacks smart contracts for bitcoin
francis suarez is a visionary leader
who's on a roll these days i mean listen
i tweeted it earlier today we have a
local politician federal government
ain't doing this the governor's not
doing this this is literally a mayor in
a city a local politician is pushing the
united states forward at an incredible
pace to make sure that we don't miss out
on this entire revolution and if we need
literally individuals or local
politicians to do it because our federal
government won't get off their ass and
get involved or we can't get the states
to actually do anything then okay great
let's get the local politicians they'll
rally around it but what we are watching
in real time we were watching the mayor
of miami take his city and plug it into
the bitcoin network that's all he's
doing he's literally plugging in i'll
take my salary and bitcoin i'm going to
give everyone a bitcoin wallet i'm going
to pay them dividends in bitcoin i'm
literally going to do everything i
possibly can to bring more and more
entrepreneurs
investors innovators builders et cetera
to this city and i am going to do
everything i possibly can to continue to
push us forward into this brand new
digital age and
he's winning
he's winning there's nobody even close
it's like you remember the meme where uh
michael phelps is swimming in one lane
and the number two guy is swimming next
to him he's looking at him and it's like
you know number one focuses on winning
number two focuses on number one that's
new york in my life if this works on a
local level as such as miami and new
york do you see this kind of being
implemented in state like the state
level the federal level like going
broader and broader if it works on just
such a small scale i think that the
cities are stronger than the states um
because you identify more with uh the
city you live in i think than with the
state like if i said to you where do you
live you don't say new york you say new
york city right where do you live some
people say florida most people say miami
right and so there's a um uh it's more
tangible it's more local to you right
it's like the city and so uh maybe it
does come to the states maybe it comes
to countries there's all kinds of things
that could happen uh but i definitely
think that um there's a world of uh uh
it being cities first and then
eventually could go i mean it could be
counties right could be towns i mean
there are all kinds of things that could
happen but cities i think is probably
the place where it finds the most uh
first
all right before we go to the next topic
let's go we've got 877 likes let's go
let's go let's go on the count of three
one two three smash the like button once
we get over a thousand we'll give out
more money john you got a winner for uh
uh the first winner wait hold on we
gotta get people to drop their twitter
account yeah drop your twitter account
in the chat right now we're gonna pick
one person we're gonna go ahead we're
gonna give out 199 with a bitcoin what
why they're doing that
go ahead i figured now is a good time uh
everyone else thank you for your service
thank you for your service
what you know what i'm talking about
give him a round of applause
applause today is veteran's day
he's embarrassed but there we go
you're lucky i didn't pull up pictures
i mean i i got a i got a dope ass photo
of me with a gold aka that's the one i
was going to pull up i didn't know if
you wanted that up there we played at
ak-47 should we get that one
uh yeah you got it you got a handful
yeah
i'll find the photo before the end of
the show but there is a photo of me in
iraq with a gold-plated ak-47 that uh
is pretty ridiculous so i'll find it
before the end of the show um but uh do
you guys uh once people drop their
twitter accounts go ahead and pick who
the uh who the winner is john while i
look for this photo very quickly
i found it
that didn't take long
you got it john yeah i got someone who
you got marco
lela
l-e-l-l-a
la la la la
199
and they actually said pay mean carrots
bitcoin whatever
carrots or bitcoin yeah
the uh matt can pull up the uh ak-47 the
uh gold-plated ak-47 in case anybody was
wondering what i was doing when i was 21
years old
i was hanging out in the desert uh
having the fun
um you said give us pay me to shoot guns
my brothers and i uh uh obviously in
hindsight you know there was a question
of when was i 17 years old and uh i uh i
signed a contract there we go
fresh little 21 year old with the
gold-plated ak-47
wait you guys like that one yeah that's
a good one that's a good photo yeah
that's a gold plate
gun from huh who'd you take the gun from
that that connex box right there is full
of all of the craziest things that got
confiscated from uh uh bad people bad
homes et cetera is that a platinum
moosie on the wall and uh yo yeah
there's some crazy stuff uh you you
wanna damn i can't believe we're doing
this right now hold on let me see if i
can find there's one there's one other
one that i got uh is that with the
bazooka yeah yeah
one picture you're like
it's not a bazooka this is never that's
like the child term for it i'm sure yeah
that's why we call it back in the day
[Laughter]
360 no scoping people bro you're not
doing [ __ ]
meet me on shipment that's my map
the two are not comparable you're you're
awesome
that's
but somebody uh somebody had it and they
were like yeah we confiscated that let
me see that photo is sick
that's pretty crazy between the 8k the
gold plated ak-47 and uh and the
homemade rpg here that was a pretty
wild-ass day uh but you know i know the
craziest part was this day there's a
bunch of people who didn't want to go
here we had to like go do like uh you
know like uh non-combat things it was on
the base we had to go like clean up or
something and we got there and i was
like damn all these guys are gonna be so
pissed they didn't come to this uh
because i got you know this photo i got
the gold-plated ak-47 there's a tommy
gun like the old school with the thing
and then uh they also just had um
uh big-ass boxes of all kinds of just
like handguns and everything that
they've taken and i was just like man
that's a lot of guns
all right on a serious note thank you
for everyone for your service uh who has
risked and given their lives to uh
defend this great nation i haven't shown
people by the way those photos probably
in almost a decade yeah
y'all sneak peek at the bazooka
you wrote along and you said shipment oh
yeah that was a good map that's what i
always messed up with a lot of action
you'd be killing people left and right
[Laughter]
all right
you good i'm great
we're gonna give out another uh we'll
give out 250 worth of bitcoin next we'll
do it uh in uh one second here
millennials don't want financial
advisors millennials are literally
taking financial advisors and bringing
them in the bathroom and getting them
swirlies they're stiff-arming them in
the hallways millennials do not want
financial advisors what am i talking
about they continue to opt out of
participating in what most people in the
boomer generation thought was the
standard way that you managed money you
had a pot of money and you were trying
to grow it and you went you found a
professional and you said hey you i
think that you're smart i'm gonna go
ahead i'm gonna pay you a little bit of
a fee you give me advice you help me
manage my money millennials are saying
nah i don't need to do that i'm smart i
can do it myself so where exactly is all
this wealth coming from young people
they're coming into money fast older
people still have a lot of wealth but
americans age 70 and above have a net
worth combined of 35 trillion dollars
about 27 of us wealth up from 20 just
three decades ago if we go ahead and we
look at this graphic here the network
net worth of people 70 and older as a
share of gdp continues to explode
upwards it's from 1990 until 2021. on
the right side you can see that the
wealth transfer that is occurring
remember 80 of american millionaires
never inherited anything but that
doesn't mean that the other 20 aren't
inheriting a hell of a lot of money and
so that wealth transfer looking like
bequests to hairs being the absolute
biggest portion of it so for people
under the age of 45
70 percent of them have or 70 of them
with a net worth of over 500k are
self-directing their own investments so
70
of people under the age of 45 with at
least 500 000 or more to their name are
choosing to say no i do not need any
help i do not need a financial advisor
if we go ahead and look at the young
wealthy households are investing on
their own and relying less on financial
advisors this is coming from the eight
norvika group analysis of federal
reserve data you can see here that
strongly self-directed is coming in real
hot and you can see that it is only
expanding more and more and more people
are saying that they are not going to
use any sort of financial advisors if we
go ahead and we look in this brand new
article that came out i think it was a
wall street journal article first
michael martucci who's the uh the
founder of swag up actually here in
miami great business if you need any
swag go to swag up he funnels 90 of his
money into cryptocurrency duh and to
check his stocks he pulls up robin hood
on his phone he doesn't need to call a
broker he doesn't need to say hey can
you call me back can we set up a meeting
can i come into the office i'll put on
my suit and tie and go play with the
financial advisors no he literally has
it on his phone we're watching
automation happen in real time does that
mean that he's got the best advice i
don't know but it seems to be working
for him travis chambers age 33 he got
nine million dollars for selling an
advertising agency he was interviewed uh
financial advisors but said they put in
too little effort they didn't mention
crypto or real estate they simply were
trying to get them to go into the stock
market and so somebody says wait i have
a red flag why am i listening to people
who don't know anything about crypto or
who don't know anything about real
estate again there are some great
financial advisors but the majority of
them do not serve their clients well for
what these young people claim that they
need and so travis put a million dollars
into a hedge fund run by his business
partner's neighbor that sounds like the
beginning of a bad story but seems to be
working out very well for him then he
invested another 1.5 million dollars to
build offbeat airbnb rentals in
low-income areas so he's got his hands
in multiple different assets some of it
he's outsourcing he's not using a
financial advisor to do it but he is
going into a hedge fund and things like
that on top of it we also see that there
are many pros to working with financial
advisors this is not a financial advisor
hit piece but financial advisors can be
helpful if they are good they can stop
emotional investing and rash decisions
they can handle complex portfolio
rebalancing and tax planning if you
don't have the time or the knowledge
they are experts in their respective
fields they can also help you plan and
keep you on track so i think that there
are actually uh financial advisors get a
bad rap because the majority of them
suck they're horrible they're non like
literally they should all be fired but
for the top maybe five percent of
financial advisors that are really
really good they should be paid ten
times more than they are so it's kind of
like anything right if you go to build a
house and you just go find any old
contractor and they suck you're like oh
all the contractors are stupid but if
you find a good one you're like hey man
i'll literally pay you anything like you
are amazing at what you do you're an
expert and so same thing with financial
advisors is that there's a lot of them
that are horrible they're literally
nonsense my favorite is always when
there's like a 23 year old financial
advisor i'm like what do you know that i
don't you're 23 you literally have no
money how could you tell me what to do
with my money and so something like uh
warren buffett says that people ride
cadillacs to wall street to take advice
from people who ride the subway
obviously you've got to be very careful
about who you're taking advice from but
if you find a good one if you find a
good financial advisor they can be worth
their weight in gold no pun intended
peter schiff what they end up doing is
they end up preventing you from making
mistakes they keep you on a plan and the
more complex your portfolio the more
that you can look and say this person is
this is their job this is what they're
focused on and so as with anything make
sure that you have high quality people
around you that are helping to give you
advice whether they are actually
financial advisors or you're just
listening to a mentor or a friend
make sure that they know what they're
doing and one of the best ways to do it
is to ask them my favorite thing to ask
a financial fighter what do you do with
your money show me your returns have you
been able to beat the s p 500 have you
been able to get your tax bill down have
you been able to build a diversified
portfolio of real estate and other
assets or are you simply trying to tell
me to do something but you're not
actually doing it with your own money
you haven't been able to do it for
yourself if you can't do it for yourself
then what makes you think that you can
tell me what i should do as well that
ends up being a really great way to do a
filter what do you guys think in terms
of
uh the financial advisor conversation i
think i think they could be helpful
right i think you hit it uh you hit it
really well which was like some of them
are really helpful and some don't do
anything i think the the concern is that
uh whether you can educate yourself on
this stuff or you need someone to help
you that's really what you have to
decide and i think we have shifted to a
world where more people are deciding to
educate themselves it's a new world
financial advisors if you look at the
incentive structure of a lot of their
contracts and their agreements they're
incentivized for you not to lose money
right and not to take many risks and not
to uh do out things outside of their
comfort zone really so we we talked
about in the past
we've talked to professional athletes
who literally their financial advisor is
not allowed to talk to them about crypto
right bitcoin whatever it is they're not
allowed to talk to them about it and
they'll ask about it and then they can
answer and they give some kind of
generalized response and push them
somewhere else right and say hey you
should do this you should do this and
what they're protecting for is not their
purchasing power they're protecting
their job and that's ultimately what a
lot of them are doing and it scales down
right that's that's obviously people
that are already wealthy but it goes to
people that aren't that wealthy either
the the greatest thing that i think you
can do in this place is get educated and
once you get educated you can decide if
you think other people can help you or
not a lot of it obviously comes down to
the time and your ability to learn a lot
of these things but the step one is just
getting educated and then you can figure
out if you need help or not
john what do you think you hit it on the
head with the incentives right i think a
lot of these financial advisors what
should happen in the future is that
instead of going on a fee based
structure of hey i managed this much in
au aum this year with this p this amount
of people i think they should go off of
results-based structure right like look
i get a small percentage right it's
similar to carry on an angel investment
um non-traditional assets are exploding
things like guys putting money into
housing in low-income areas to crypto to
all these other assets that these
financials are these financial providers
are lagging a little bit behind and or
they can't talk about or anything like
that so that's one thing if you don't
have the time or the knowledge you
should definitely have a financial
advisor they're only really going to
help you in that aspect
but look access to information has
changed rapidly over the last few
decades and that's what we're seeing is
people taking control with that access
to information learning about themselves
and then saying look i don't need you to
pay you that percent i can just do it
myself yeah having great results and i
would say like that that education is
definitely uh is filtering down somewhat
there's still a long long long way to go
but there's a general narrative that
financial advisor don't know anything
about crypto and that's not true right
we know personally
many financial advisors that are heavy
into crypto and allocated a large
portion of their portfolio the thing is
you have to look at it from the top down
right a lot of these firms are
prioritizing the ability to maintain
their client base and maintain aum and
maintain fees and all this stuff right
and the easiest way to do that is not to
lose clients money or risk their money
and granted bitcoin and other uh crypto
assets have gone up a lot recently so
they lost out on all of those gains but
what they're doing is they're just
protecting themselves so although the
financial advisor may be uh in it a lot
personally understand a lot about it be
extremely educated about it they're not
always able to talk about these things
and the the only person that really lose
out on that is the client right the
person that's paying this financial
advisor for the advice and if you're
doing something else with your money
right and you're the you're the smart
person in the room that knows what
they're talking about you would expect
those uh those ideas to be filtered down
to your client but in a lot of these
cases they're not being
two two thoughts on this one peter's
late he literally has emailed me six
times right now trying to get the link i
keep sending it to him so i don't know
what's going on over there uh but
hopefully he will be here uh shortly on
top of that uh i see uh mike christensen
in the chat
he i still not figured out how the super
chat thing works but he looks like he uh
paid five dollars to explicitly say i'm
a crypto friendly financial advisor and
killing it this year
so shout out mike i appreciate that uh i
i do think that um you know look it it's
uh it's easy to like punch down on and
uh mock the 80 90 percent of advisors
that suck like there are some that are
horrendous horrendous
but the ones that are good man
it's uh it's pretty good somebody said
that they're going to meet their
financial advisor at the slots in las
vegas
well a lot of it too is just
relationship driven right it's it's
people that have relationships and are
are friendly with people and have good
uh connections but ultimately that's not
really what you're paying for right
you're paying to have your money
protected your purchasing power
protected your taxes done you're paying
to be advised on these things so you
need to take a hard look and see if your
financial advisor is doing that if you
were a financial advisor starting right
out of school what would you do because
they just basically i would go i would
go become rich first before i became a
financial advisor
right
how do i know what to do
i if i can't do it for myself how am i
going to tell my clients what to do
simple elegantly put show me your bank
account that's my question of the
financial advisor show me your bank
account you got more cash than me all
right how'd you do it you ain't got more
cash than me than a all right
i mean like let's just let's just speak
facts here right
if you don't have more money than me how
are you going to tell me to get more
money you can't get more money for
yourself right but if you got more money
than me how'd you do it it's like you
like those returns real quick
we're going to bring peter on here in a
second right but uh uh what i always say
is it's like the floyd mayweather uh uh
clip right where he's like look i have
all these billionaire friends i'd go
over they'd show me their yachts their
helicopters their planes all the stuff
he's like this is awesome man but i
can't be your friend if you just want me
to come over and go on your yacht you
got to show me how to get the yacht and
then we can be friends because i want my
own yacht i want to pull my yacht up
next to your yacht but if you just want
me to come on your yacht then hey
whatever you're wasting my time i got to
go figure out how to do it somewhere
else same thing with a financial advisor
is if you're just going to sit here and
you're going back well i read this book
and i told me to do whatever okay cool
show me your bank account if you got
more cash than me how did you do it now
now we can be for now i'm interested now
i'll pay you a lot of money but if you
got more money than me then it sounds
like this is just a tax they don't call
us johnny jets and and joey yeah that's
for nothing yeah whatever
what if their returns are greater than
yours on a percentage basis but they
don't have an uh the same amount of
capital that you have because you built
a business elsewhere that would be a
good retort if they didn't have more
money than me right and by the way i'm
not rich i'm just chilling right but
like hey if you could show up and you
could say hey by the way you returned 10
a year and i returned 40 okay well i'm
interested like show me how you do that
so there's different things some
evidence i think is what you're saying
yeah yeah yeah but like kind of let's
just call it let's just call it space
you got more cash than me all right
let's go all right peter what's going on
man
hey how you guys doing you know first of
all i can't help but overhear your
conversation you know there's nothing
wrong with going on your friend's yacht
because you know yachts are expensive i
don't know if you have any idea how much
it costs to maintain them it's a lot
better if somebody else is uh paying for
it and you just get you just get to ride
along
oh but but
all he's saying is he just wants to have
enough money to buy the yacht if you do
it doesn't mean you got to buy the yacht
but just [ __ ] yeah no you will it's it's
much better to rent them you know what
they say about uh floating and flying i
won't finish the quote uh but uh it's
better it's better to rent but you know
your comments about financial advisors
are are true i remember when i first got
started and i was a financial advisor i
hardly had any money and neither did
anybody else who was giving advice our
clients had a lot more money than we did
i mean we didn't know what we were doing
uh you know we were just pitching stocks
and uh
but yeah i mean a lot of people who are
giving financial advice have no money
and and and a lot of the brokers i knew
were terrible with their own money they
spent everything they did they didn't
they had nothing left over to invest
because they blew it all because they
got to look like they're rich that's the
other problem with financial advisors
they gotta look like the rich they gotta
have the rolex which is fake probably
they gotta also have a nice office they
gotta drive a car that they probably
leased and didn't buy they gotta pretend
to be rich but just that's the way the
clearest way to cut through the [ __ ]
show me your bank account i'll show you
mine you're gonna be my financial
advisor right show me your pickup let me
show you mine well apparently your bank
account is all bitcoins exactly that's
what that's why i'm probably smarter
than them all right tell me about
inflation well beto also one other thing
about these financial advisors
i would be very nervous if i was a
financial advisor putting anybody in
crypto because you know when that bubble
pops there's gonna be a lot of lawsuits
and it's easy to sue your financial
advisor you know you just go and get a
contingency lawyer you do it through
finra
uh and so it's i think i think people
are taking a lot of risk it's one thing
to gamble with your own money like that
but it's another thing to gamble with uh
client money that's true that's true all
right talk to me about inflation six
point two percent cpi yesterday uh about
four and a half percent core inflation
do you believe these numbers
no actually the numbers are worse uh as
bad as they are reality is worse i mean
first of all we know what's going on
with rent right with uh owner's
equivalent rent
which the government uses in replace of
actual rent
and actual rents are rising four times
faster than what you know owner's
equivalent rent and of course home
prices don't even make it into the cpi
at all and they're way up so people who
want to buy houses you know they're
looking at even bigger price increases
than the people who want to rent them
but i think a lot of the other
um you know numbers are massaged the way
they are you know put through the the
methodology for computing the the uh the
number you know they they substitute
things if things go up they they don't
count them uh there the whole system is
rigged to give you a low number
and despite the rigging we still have
almost seven percent if you annualize
the first 10 months of this year
uh and then you know it's almost seven
percent inflation uh mentioned by the
cpi so
you know even the government number is
bad but reality is much worse
when you think about the inflation
numbers themselves it's very obvious
that things like food gasoline etc are
all uh exploding one of the takeaways
that i had from the cpi numbers was that
whether food at home or food out of the
home was both up over five percent how
do you think about the basket of goods
in terms of the things that people spend
a lot of money on rent food uh utilities
versus maybe some of the more um kind of
uh uh infrequent type of goods that they
may consume it feels like the things
that i really care about those are
actually up pretty materially and then
there's a bunch of stuff that maybe i
care maybe i don't but but i just use
them less frequently
yeah if you measure the cost of living
if you actually look at the basket of
goods and services that
people are buying i think that basket is
going up faster than some of the goods
that people may not buy at all you know
or may just buy
once in a while you know if you look at
let's say a laptop computer how often do
you buy a new laptop i mean maybe every
few years i mean some people wait longer
than that they make do with the one they
have but you're buying groceries every
week right you're buying gasoline every
week you're paying your electric bill uh
so there are a lot of things that you
know you the higher prices you got to
pay some of the things if the prices are
down a little bit you may not even be
buying them because you're spending so
much money on the things you need you
don't even have that much money left
over for some of the other things that
you want
when you also think about things like
employment how do you settle in your
mind that there is 11 million open jobs
and nearly 5 unemployment number like
how are those two things possible to be
operating at the exact same time well
either the people who are unemployed
don't want those jobs
or they're not qualified for those jobs
but that is a problem in the economy
when you have a lot of job openings that
workers neither want nor qualify for
and so the question is why are they not
qualified and why don't they want them
and i think there are different answers
to those questions but certainly one
reason that people may not want jobs is
maybe they got a better deal from the
government they uh they'd rather collect
benefits than collect a paycheck because
you have to work for the paycheck but i
also think there's a lot of young people
maybe they got a lot of cryptocurrency
and they're just trading or they're
trading stocks on their robinhood app
and you know it's a bubble and they
think they're geniuses and maybe they're
making enough money just trading crypto
or or stocks and they figure they don't
need a job
i'm gonna drop some heat on you you
ready i'm gonna tell you two theories i
have and you tell me if you think uh
that they're actually correct or if i'm
full of [ __ ] first one is uh a lot of
these people who are quote unquote not
working not in the workforce they do
have jobs they just have jobs that
previously people haven't uh identified
or they have investment gains that uh
people also haven't identified so i'll
give you a very uh quick example there's
a kid that i recently met he had a uh
for all intents and purposes a normal
job that people would would uh say okay
you work for this employer et cetera
previously he then started to get into
all of this crypto world and he began
working for these dows and think of them
as uh similar to an organization uh
they're just not legally uh the exact
same thing they don't have employment
contracts all of that but he's getting
the equivalent of a salary or some sort
of payment for doing some actions but
that's not showing up in any of the
employment data and the job that he left
i'm guessing is now showing up as one of
the 11 million open roles because
they're going to try to fill it with
somebody else and so is there a world
where we could try to identify whether
it's like the super uh kind of long tail
crypto stuff or literally somebody now
is running a media business where
they're posting photos on instagram and
getting paid by advertisers but they
don't have an llc they're not using it
like a traditional business owner would
is there a way to start to identify like
how many of the people who are not in
the traditional workforce are actually
operating a job it's just kind of a new
type of job
remember you're not considered
unemployed if you're not looking for
work so if you're content to be
self-employed you're not unemployed so
you wouldn't be part of the statistics
uh but certainly you know there are
going to be people that are in the
underground economy that are working for
cash uh but i don't know if they show up
on the unemployment rolls either they
may just show up as you know no longer
in the labor force if they're if they
don't claim to be employed but they're
actually employed under the table and
they're working for cash you know and
you're always going to have a
you know a certain amount of that going
on
uh you know people have a you know
preference for cash because they they
don't pay taxes most people i mean
that's why i think when you see the byte
administration talking about you know
cracking down on tax cheats that's
really who they're after it's the gig
worker who gets paid cash or the small
business owner who uh gets some of his
income in cash and doesn't report it or
maybe takes a lot of personal exemptions
and claims them as business expenses
that's where they're looking because
that's where all the tax evasion is
taking place you know they're really
rich they don't have to evade the taxes
they just legally avoid them and and
they don't want to risk tax evasion it's
not worth it to them but for a lot of
middle class people it's worth the risk
because if they paid their taxes
honestly they couldn't feed their family
they couldn't pay the rent uh so the
only way they can get by uh given how
high the taxes are and how weak the
economy is is you know to try to cheat
on their taxes
so when you start to think about uh well
actually i want to make one point very
quickly is peter schiff just called
instagram the underground economy
which i appreciate
but it kind of is the underground
economy uh it is also um supply chain
supply chains keep coming up in this
conversation around inflation i
i don't want to make too many
assumptions here but i'm assuming that
you agree uh monetary and fiscal policy
decisions have been absolutely insane
and undisciplined but also there are
supply chain disruptions as well there's
kind of two uh of many factors that are
at play here is there a world where we
can assign some of the blame for the
supply chain disruptions on the monetary
and fiscal policy by giving all these
people money they go spend a ton of it
it puts strain on the supply chain and
that's what leads to some of the
breakage
it's all the consequence of monetary and
fiscal policy i mean you can try to
blame it on supply but but
that's not what's going on here i mean i
talked about this from the beginning the
minute that covet hit
the correct policy response was for the
government to cut spending because the
economy was contracting people weren't
working uh and they weren't producing
goods and services but the government
did the opposite of what they should
have done the government said hey we
have to make sure that people who are no
longer working keep spending money
why they're not earning money how can
they spend they're not producing
anything but we sent everybody home and
said don't produce stuff
and here's more money and you can now
out go out and buy even more stuff now
unemployed when you're not working than
you used to buy when you actually
contributed uh to the production of
goods and services so we simultaneously
reduced the production of goods and
services and we gave people a lot more
money to go into the market and buy the
goods and services that we weren't even
producing
uh and but what's driving the price is
the fact that we did the wrong thing we
should have we should have encouraged
people not to spend because they weren't
working we needed people to spend less
but instead they spent more but on what
we weren't making this stuff so the
prices are going up and you know now
if you look at
the the imports
we have record imports we are importing
more than we've ever imported before
that the volume is a record right not
only are the deficits of record but the
imports are a record so we've got more
supply coming in from the rest of the
world than we've ever had in the past
the problem is we've got too much money
to spend it on and
americans are not producing because
we're more reliant on foreigners because
to say hey it's about covid that's why
we're not producing well why is china
producing why is the rest of the world
producing because they have record
exports china has the largest trade
surpluses in history because it's making
all this stuff and sending it to america
i mean they have coveted over there in
china too yet how come they produce all
this stuff and we don't
uh the problem is we have a more
reckless monetary policy and a much
weaker uh economy fundamentally because
we're not producing we're just producing
money right but but when the federal
reserve prints money and gives it to
people to spend that doesn't mean
there's more stuff to buy so if you got
more money to buy the stuff well the
price of this stuff has to go up that's
that's basic supply and demand that's
what inflation is it's an expansion of
the money supply rising prices are just
a consequence of inflation so all this
talk about the government trying to
scapegoat uh supplied bottlenecks or the
economy reopening and ignoring the
elephant in the room which is massive
money printing by the federal reserve to
finance huge deficits by the federal
government that's it
what questions you guys have for peter
peter how you doing thanks for joining
us again
uh so we had 6.2 this month do you think
next month will come in higher or lower
and if it's higher uh how bad do you
think it can get
well i've been taking the over on cpi
every month i mean i i generally think
that's the safer bet
um the you know the markets are usually
disappointed when the number comes in
higher than expected the only thing
that's interesting now and this is
recent because it happened again
uh this month is we got
a hotter than expected inflation number
and the price of gold went up it was up
about 18 bucks yesterday it's up another
10 today
and you know that's what you would
expect right you would expect gold to go
up on high inflation but what had been
happening is that we'd get higher than
expected inflation numbers and gold
would sell off sometimes you know 20 30
bucks and the reason for that is the
market is still foolish enough to
believe that these higher inflation
numbers mean the fed is going to have to
react to put out the fire the fed is
going to have to get tough on inflation
it's going to fight inflation with more
aggressive uh
tapering or rate hikes and so gold
always factors that in and sells off
because the markets start looking
forward to this tighter policy what the
markets still don't get is a the fed's
probably not going to try to fight
inflation
and b
even if it does it's going to lose
because it will not be able to raise
rates enough
in order to make a difference you know
if inflation is seven eight percent by
the time the fed gets around to the
first rate hike i mean how is it going
to do anything i mean if the fed goes
from zero to 25 basis points half a
percent even if they go up to one
percent what difference does that make
when inflation is eight percent you are
so far behind the curve that there's
nothing you could do the fed would have
to jump out in front of the curve so if
inflation is eight percent the first
rate hike has to be like to ten percent
you got to get out in front of that
curve to bend it but of course that's
never going to happen i mean we're not
going to get any real rate hikes i mean
they had to stop the rate hikes in 2018
at two and a half percent because
everything started to collapse well if
we collapse the two and a half percent
in 2018 we're not going to get anywhere
near that high now because we have so
much more debt today than we had back
then thanks to all the stimulus that has
occurred since that point in time
john what questions you got yeah peter
nice to see you again um i know you're
having a good day gold was up yesterday
so can you talk about
the official numbers are 6.2 percent for
inflation we can beat the drum all day
how long do you think inflation's gonna
last in this kind of environment with
this six plus percent
oh it it's here for the duration i mean
i mean this decade is going to be a big
inflationary decade i mean it's it's
going to get worse it's going to be much
worse in the 70s i just don't see a way
out really uh you know we got out of it
with paul volcker and ronald reagan
in uh you know 1980 i mean i don't see a
reagan on the horizon in the white house
we're not going to get another paul
volcker
uh and and even if we had paul volcker i
mean what how could they raise rates i
mean in in 1980
when the fed raised rates it only
impacted the new budget deficits
it didn't impact the national debt
because the national debt was financed
with 30-year treasury bonds today the
national debt is financed with t-bills
we got almost a 30 trillion dollar
national debt if they had to jack
interest rates up let's say even at 10
we would pretty much have to refinance
the whole national debt in three years
at 10
right now we got it financed at you know
like one percent two percent i mean
really low
where would the government get trillions
of additional dollars to pay the
interest on the debt plus we already
have three four trillion dollar year
deficits which would get much bigger if
the fed actually raised interest rates
to 10
what would happen to the economy i mean
it would implode i mean think about the
real estate market the stock market i
mean everything would collapse so the
deficits would skyrocket and of course
how would they pay the interest so we're
in a position where we can't raise rates
in 1980 america still had trade
surpluses now we have huge record trade
deficits in 1980 america was the world's
biggest creditor nation now we're the
world's biggest debtor nation there's no
way we can survive the cure for
inflation the cure for inflation would
kill the economy which is why we're not
going to get it which is why inflation
is here to stay and it's going to keep
getting worse and all the people can do
or the powers that be is
it kind of dismiss it it's transitory
and eventually when they can't claim
it's transitory anymore they'll say it's
a good thing it's a sign of our
prosperity it's just a price we have to
pay for a strong growing economy you
know they're going to keep on saying all
that until eventually they're going to
go with the price controls you know
you know we did that early on in the
1970s you know inflation is already
worse today than it was when nixon put
wage and price controls on how high do
you think inflation can go in the future
well how high is it really going to go
or how high will the government admit
because they can keep doctoring that cpi
right because i think you know it's
already probably you know 10 15 percent
for
um
2021. i mean if you look at the import
export prices because those things
aren't you know manipulated as much as
the cpi that's what you're seeing look
at the price of imports and exports are
soaring like 15 to 20
you know this year
uh so that's probably a better
indication of what's actually going on
uh but you know i think even the way the
government measures inflation we could
end up moving into double digits but by
the time the cpi is registering 10 11
you know we're going to be over 20
peter i have two questions one what is
the next step in their view this is me
allowing you to create a receipt that we
can come back to later as they continue
to doctor the cpi number what's the most
likely thing they do next to try to keep
that number uh kind of sub 10 percent
well i don't know they could they could
find new ways of
changing the index you know introducing
more uh hedonics you know claiming that
things are getting better that the
quality is improving
of course they'll ignore all the
examples where the equality is is being
diminished
and they can also substitute more things
you know and just say oh well the price
of meat went way up so you know let's
just people are eating chicken you know
they're not you know and so but then
eventually it's like well they're not
eating chicken they're eating dog food
but that's okay because they're still
eating so you know there's no inflation
uh they could just keep you know
taking things out of the basket that are
going up and and throwing other things
in there uh to try to pretend that that
prices aren't rising
uh but you know the public's gonna see
it you know they're i mean that's one
thing they're smart enough to figure out
is what they're paying for stuff and you
know there's only there's a limit to how
small the packaging can get because
initially
you've got the um
the the companies try to put the price
increases through by just diminishing
the quantity you know but then you open
up a box of cereal and you know through
the top three quarters of the box is
just cardboard right the cereal doesn't
start you know so it's there's only
there's only so small you can make the
packaging
you know and they do that you know how i
mean how many sheets can you take out of
a roll of toilet paper i mean you can't
sell toilet paper by the sheet right all
right like a slice of pizza like you
know
but uh so at some point they just got to
raise the prices
all right i think you may have froze but
i can still hear you but yeah i i saw my
uh my my my screen froze well i mean
look it's because you're still using
dial up and the rest of us are on wi-fi
but
i do need new equipment that's for sure
here and i'm trying to build a studio
but you know things take a while out
here in puerto rico
all right so here's my question my guy
paul's coming in here to fix it now all
right well what i really wanted to ask i
wish i could see your face because i
want to see you squirm when i ask this
question i don't look any different than
i looked a minute ago
no i know but when i ask this question
you're going to squirm and that's what i
need really
that's what i need to see come on paul
let's go fix it where's paul at trying
to fix it
by the way while we're waiting my son
says check your text he's been texting
you you said you haven't responded i i i
told him he has been he has been he has
been but i just wanted everyone to
remember that one time tell them i'll
respond when we get done with this but
uh one time peter facetimed his son when
his son was a bitcoin conference and he
was sitting there and i grabbed his
phone and i answered the facetime he
should have seen peter's family what the
hell
are you ready
yeah yeah you tweeted that gold was up
18 yesterday and you were taking a
victory lap on the internet 18 just fell
out of my pocket what are you doing on
the internet with your 18 at golden why
are you celebrating that
no no i wasn't just celebrating anything
and first of all you know i own a lot of
things in addition to gold i mean you
think you know i got i gold is a small
part of my portfolio right i mean i have
a lot of gold stocks so in that respect
that's a pretty big part you said in
reaction to hotter than expected
inflation data gold rose 18 closing near
1 850 per ounce it's the highest level
in five months but while bitcoin
initially pumped to a new all-time high
bitcoin hit an all-time high close to 69
000 the ensuing dump senate tumbling 8.5
back below 63 000 at the low i don't
know that sounds like a victory lap 18
near a five month high the point i was
making uh anthony
the point i was making you're squirming
gold gold actually reacted to higher
inflation by going up bitcoin reacted to
it by going down now what happened
initially is i think some of the whales
that want to unload bitcoin the minute
they saw that hot print they're like
okay let's buy some bitcoin and try to
get some excitement around this
inflation number gold's going up let's
make bitcoin go up and they come in
there and they buy and they get people
oh you see even my son got excited look
dad look at bitcoin going up on the
inflation numbers right so they got all
this excitement and as soon as they got
the herd all excited then they dumped it
right they took advantage of the pump
and they came out big time selling their
bitcoin and it went crashing down so i
think the whole initial move up was all
the manipulated attempt to unload
bitcoin it wasn't like ah you see
bitcoin is reacting to the inflation is
bitcoin's got nothing to do with
inflation it's not inflation hedge it's
not a commodity it's not a real asset
you know it's just it's just a you know
it's it's a risk asset and it goes up
when people want to buy it you know it
doesn't get anything to do with
inflation nothing to do with other
commodities i don't know anything doing
the gold
but obviously that's part of the story
that's part of the phony narrative
that's used to generate demand for
bitcoin is that it's gold uh and but
they were able to manipulate it up but
the fact that it got killed so strongly
shows you that there are people that are
waiting to sell
that spike and i think the people who
sold it are the same people who helped
create it now maybe they didn't use the
same wallets you know maybe they have
some wallets where they buy and then
they have other wallets where they dump
uh but it seemed to me that that's
exactly what was going on
all right are you last question for you
and then we got to go we got other
things to do you were late so you know i
got i got all kinds of lady you sent us
the link no i sent you the link six
times uh did are you changing anything
about your portfolio after the uh cpi
print yesterday
no i mean my portfolio went up you know
be you know although you know obviously
the dollar the dollar went up and again
that shouldn't be happening the dollar
had a big update yesterday on the cpi
which of course inflation
lets you know that the dollar is losing
value so the fact that the dollar is
losing purchasing power faster is not
bullish for the dollar it's bearish but
again the currency traders bit up the
dollar because they expect the fed to
successfully fight off inflation they're
wrong as i said earlier so you know but
i'm short the dollar and that all of my
investments are international so i have
all my stuff in asia and europe and
australia new zealand you know south
america so i i got these foreign assets
but by and large uh my fa most of my
foreign stocks were up yesterday even as
the u.s market was down but the biggest
winners were the gold stocks they're all
up again today but now you know some of
my copper stocks and uh you know are
having a bigger a bigger days today than
than my gold stocks uh you know i also
have a lot of energy exposure i have a
lot of assets that i think are going to
be real inflation hedges that's why i
don't own any bitcoin i don't think
bitcoin is an inflation hedge even
though some people think it is uh you
know it's i think i look at bitcoin like
any of these other overpriced meme
stocks i mean they can keep going up uh
so long as you know the crowd uh you
know is gonna believe the story uh but
eventually uh you know reality sets in
i'm just not smart enough to know when
all right i've let you say your piece i
think you're wrong you think i'm wrong
we'll see what happens but well you
ought to hedge yourself at least i mean
you know
i hedge myself by talking to you once a
month
numbers
what do you what else do you own besides
bitcoin wha why do i need to own
anything else that's c that's what i
just said you got to hedge yourself what
if i'm right bitcoin is the hedge peter
broke
all right i appreciate it thank you
everyone go follow peter on twitter he
uh is full of great uh memes
lots of good economics the reason why i
bring you on it because you actually
really do understand the economy very
well you understand macroeconomics you
understand uh monetary fiscal policy
your gold fascination i you know i don't
know what's going on there but i forgive
you no problem
i understand bitcoin too
all right see you later my friend all
right thank you speeder
what do you guys think
he's awesome
by the way how about him coming in hot
and saying yeah financial advisors i
didn't know [ __ ]
yeah none of them know [ __ ]
except for the good ones yeah um all
right real quick right we are we're
getting lynn alden we're gonna bring
lynn on here in a second uh go ahead one
two three smash the like button we're
going to give out 200
worth of bitcoin right now all you have
to do is drop your twitter account or
your instagram twitter or instagram just
drop it here in the chat and then we
will bring lynn on we're going to pick
one person right now before we go live
joe maybe you pick all right who you got
for us joe well i got to see some
twitter accounts let's go get your
twitter account put mine in there
john's going to put is it trying to
can't get picked don't worry
all right all right all right
you got somebody joe
uh yeah we got steve norman steve norman
you win 200. worth of bitcoin we got
twitter account already good to go good
job good job john taught me you don't
pick people that don't put the twitter
account exactly
i need some congratulations i need i
need some love
we need some positivity going on around
here all of a sudden we get somebody
wins 200 worth of bitcoin that's what i
need from you guys i need you guys to
say congratulations
what is wrong with you today what are
you talking about i'm excited about
talking to lynn you know why why because
she understands uh bitcoin very well
she's like the modern-day uh peter
schiff because she understands the
economy she understands inflation is
monetary fiscal policy but she also
understands bitcoin peter thinks he does
but
he hasn't bought it which means he
doesn't it's all right it's all right uh
all right i think we are uh ready lynn
are you there
i'm here how are you i'm doing very well
how are you
i'm pretty good all right you have a
great act to follow peter schiff was
just on and he nailed all of the
economic talk and then you know kind of
fell off at the end talking about
bitcoin but uh i told everyone that
you're going to uh to bring us home uh
yesterday 6.2 cpi what was your just
overall read were you expecting this
high of a cpi print or did that catch
you by surprise to the upside
i didn't have a firm view on exactly
what it would be so nothing between say
five and six and a half percent would
have been surprising my overall high
conviction view that it was going to be
sticky at these elevated levels for at
least at least a few more quarters uh
because we're seeing basically
especially rent inflation and owner's
equivalent rent inflation those official
components of the cpi which are kind of
like wonky ways to measure actual rent
increases and actual housing price
increases those are on the uptrend and
so those were the clear drivers of a lot
of the inflation pressures uh and so i
didn't have an exact number in mind but
yeah this wasn't surprising and one of
my overall views you know going back
over the past year was that we would get
inflation uh and that also we'd have a
big disconnect between inflation and
interest rates so people holding cash or
treasuries are not getting adequate
amounts of interest to cover their you
know loss of purchasing power so it's
essentially a currency devaluation going
on okay so you had a thread yesterday
we're gonna talk about a couple of these
uh just to start with and the second
tweet in this thread you said it looks a
lot like the 1940s and you pulled up a a
chart that basically had the fed holding
the interest rates low despite the uh
periodic inflation um and then you also
showed the 1970s as well and so maybe
talk a little bit just about what was
happening in the 40s and the 70s that uh
you see a lot of similarities
sure so those were the two inflationary
decades of the past century uh in the
united states uh and so in the 1970s
that's what a lot of people think of as
the inflationary decade but it's
actually a somewhat less viable example
here it has some overlap obviously so in
the 70s
you know dead as a percentage of gdp at
that point was very low they had already
inflated away a lot of debt from the 40s
uh in the 50s
and so actually you know public debt as
a percentage of gdp was something like
30 percent um and private debt wasn't
that bad either
and so overall you had a pretty low debt
environment but we had other issues
obviously so basically they they had you
know spent decades drawing down their
gold reserves to to you know support the
bretton wood system which is what the
dollar was pegged to gold and they
couldn't really back that anymore and
two u.s oil production peaked in 1970 uh
representing a real world constraint and
they had they had to import more of
their oil um and so basically you had
this this combined scenario where they
you know they went off the gold standard
um so that broke the money system uh and
then they actually had that inflationary
component of oil restrictions and then
also there were geopolitical issues
obviously in the middle east
and so for a while that was a very
inflationary period and as you can see
on the chart there the fed kept trying
to raise interest rates uh to combat
inflation um but they were generally you
know they weren't decisive with it they
were slow they kept saying it's
transitory uh sounds familiar um and so
they fought this for a while and it
wasn't until the very end where a number
of factors relating to demographics as
well as pulver volcker coming in and
jacking up interest rates super high he
basically put the economy into recession
in order to stabilize the the dollar the
purchasing power uh so that that's how
that decade went now if we go back to
the 40s it was a different environment
because
most of the inflation was driven by
fiscal spending whereas in the 70s it
was a combination of a lot of things as
part of the fiscal spending a lot of it
was bank loan growth right whereas in
the 40s it was almost entirely gigantic
war spending
and so we often think of war spending as
foreign spending but actually most of it
is spending on the domestic economy
they're building factories they're
paying for gi bills uh you know a lot of
the programs are somewhat similar to
what we saw over the past year and a
half
but obviously tailored towards more
industrial purposes
and so you had this this massive
increase the money supply from the
fiscal spending which was monetized by
the fed and so you had a natural you had
an inflationary component especially
because also every country in the world
was trying to get as many commodities as
they could right so there's a lot of
commodity demand
and so you had a very inflation
environment the difference was that
because federal debt as a percentage of
gdp was 130 percent they could raise
interest rates to five percent or 10
percent or higher because it would
bankrupt the government so they they had
no choice they just had to hold interest
rates low
despite the fact that inflation was high
and so if you were holding cash or
treasuries you just got annihilated on
an inflation-adjusted basis for like the
for like a nine-year period where they
just held rates super low even though
inflation peaked at 19 year-over-year in
the 40s uh and the overall average
inflation for that decade was about six
percent and you just sat there earning
roughly zero percent of your t bills and
roughly two and a half percent on your
longer longer dated treasury bonds so
when you look at this uh you had a
second tweet that basically said this is
the widest gap that we've had on record
uh and you'd have to go back to the 40s
and kind of situation you're talking
about there is your thought process that
we now are entering the exact same
situation where they're gonna have to
keep the rates low uh for a decade or so
and we can look to the 40s as the actual
guide for what to expect moving forward
or do you think there's some
similarities but we may get uh kind of a
different outcome or a different action
one they obviously have the hindsight of
what happened in the 40s and 70s but
also they may have some some different
thoughts in terms of what to do moving
forward
so i find that that the 40s is the most
instructive analogy to be familiar with
basically i would say it's not going to
be identical to that there are
differences that i can go over but
anyone who's not familiar with the 40s
is going to be for a rough time i think
and and confused about markets
and so it's a useful period to study in
terms of fiscal monetary policy so i
would say in those areas fiscal monetary
policy it's likely to be very similar to
the to the 1940s there are some
differences and and so obviously there's
a different geopolitical environment
we're not in a world war instead there's
you know basically spending related to
you know uh
lockdown things and and basically fiscal
stimulus in that regard so there's still
kind of similar fiscal environment but
it's for different purposes uh there's
very different demographics in the
developed world right so you have much
older population and so some of these
structural deficits um
aren't really going to go away anytime
soon uh whereas in the at the end of
world war ii they were able to
eventually you know get their deficit
away at least for several years
um and so there's differences there and
another uh difference is that the united
states back then was a creditor nation
and a trade surplus nation so we were
like a rising power we were producing
more than we were importing uh and we
owned more foreign assets than foreign
of our assets uh whereas in this period
the united states is the world's biggest
debtor nation we have a structural trade
deficit so in some ways we actually look
more like the united kingdom looked in
the 1940s uh meaning that we you know
they were the existing kind of world
reserve currency they were the ones
running structural trade deficits um and
and the united states was counting the
china back then they were the one that
were that was coming up with massive gdp
growth they were the ones you know
making things for the world um and so
the the roles are somewhat flipped here
so there are important differences to be
aware of i think one final difference is
that in terms of the equity market it's
a pretty different environment because
we went into the 40s
equity evaluations were very low you
just came out of the 1930s depressionary
period uh and then obviously the the
beginning of the war years were not
going very well so basically until there
were major victories in the pacific
equities were very very low valued and
they started to rise after that when you
had these inflationary pressures and a
week and when it became increasingly
obvious that the united states was going
to uh win the war uh and that things
were going to go you know pretty well at
the end uh and so going into this
environment obviously it's it's very
high equity valuations
and in many ways that actually does look
close to the 70s because you had very
very high valuations in the late 60s
early 70s going into that inflationary
period
and so that can certainly affect how
equities perform on an
inflation-adjusted basis between these
two environments when you start to look
across asset classes i know you've done
a ton of work looking at everything from
public equities to obviously the bond
market uh crypto et cetera
it feels like uh being invested has been
the trade for the last 18 to 24 months
right just uh you could almost pick any
market as long as you were investing you
weren't holding cash you've done pretty
well uh how does this change as we get
deeper and deeper into this and it feels
like there's almost this element where
uh every time we get towards a market
correction or what could be the start of
a bear market there's just something
that comes up it's like they're reaching
their toolbox and whether it's uh some
sort of guidance whether it's some sort
of actual spending bill um or some sort
of action and i joke all the time that
like bear markets have been banned and
market corrections are outlawed and like
it's just everything has to go up
is that actually true or is is there
just like some correlation between the
actions they're taking and has that
impact but they will actually allow us
to have kind of more prolonged market
corrections and maybe even a bear market
in one of those kind of core asset
classes
so i think that i think a bear market
can happen especially in in real terms
right so obviously if if if markets go
flat for a decade but inflation averages
six percent for the decade that's really
poor performance in real terms even
though we don't think of it as like a
big market crash for example uh and so i
i kind of look towards that
possibilities being somewhat likely and
there's a couple catalysts to look for i
would say so one is
um
you know basically
if interest rates were to rise uh that
that would be very detrimental to the
equity market i mean if treasury rates
uh go up to three four or five percent
right that would be that'd be
devastating for some of these especially
these really high valued growth stocks
that are like unprofitable growth stocks
that we that we were we're happy to pay
10 or 15 or
more times earnings for um times revenue
for uh because you know basically
interest rates are so low alternatives
are so low we're betting on their future
out 10 years those if those discount
rates go up dramatically that puts a lot
of pressure on those big companies and
then also including some of the big fan
companies that really kind of drive a
lot of the s p 500 so that would be a
risk now if interest rates stay low and
inflation stays hot that's a that's a
trickier outcome the catalyst i would
look for there
would be if the feds basically stops
doing qe
because qe
you know qe is a complicated thing
because the inflation we're seeing is
largely due to fiscal spending and other
measures which qe supports but qb on its
own is not necessarily inflationary as
we saw from the you know the 2010s
decade where they did qe but it just
stayed in the banking system because
there's no fiscal
spending to really get that out into the
into the economy and so instead it just
inflated asset prices uh and so i would
say that if you get an environment
that's that's rather inflationary and it
becomes somewhat self-sustaining with
with wages going up and therefore prices
going up and then for therefore wages
going up and therefore prices going up
if that becomes a more self-sustaining
loop
and if they've if they slow down qe or
nqe that could be a rougher time for for
equity markets uh because you have less
of that asset price inflation most
likely
and you still have this this underlying
real inflation going on
when you think about somebody like jack
dorsey and square obviously they have a
very incredible data set one of the
things i'm fascinated by is not only is
it a data set of point of sale uh data
but also they have everything from the
payroll data uh for uh companies that
they work with they also have the
consumer cash app they have cards uh
they kind of have in my eyes kind of a
360 view of many data points uh both in
real time lots of them and across a
diverse set of market participants and
so i continue to say that that is in my
opinion one of the most valuable data
sets uh in evaluating some of this
do you have any thoughts about what the
data would show if somebody could
actually see that versus like the
government's
ability to collect some of this data and
analyze and use like cost of living
index baskets and things like that like
how do you think about the data we're
looking at and i use that as a proxy for
if we have bad data that we're going to
make bad decisions regardless but what
are your thoughts on that
i think they could certainly construct a
probably a a more accurate or real-time
inflation measure uh in the company i
don't know if they have one but they i
think they could with their data
and it's basically it's also clear from
jack's tweets he's been looking at macro
stuff so he's he's like looking at
probably the you know that wtf happened
in 1971 site um
he's he's been mentioning alternative
ways to measure inflation i obviously
had that famous hyperinflation tweet
he's been looking at at obviously some
of those macro things
and so
i don't know exactly what he has in
terms of internal data but if they if
they wanted to construct an internal
inflation measure they could and an
example i use like so if you if you go
back to that renting
inflation and owner's equipment rent
inflation so house house pricing used to
be included in the inflation basket uh
if you back in like the the early 80s uh
and before then uh and so if if houses
go up 20
that would that would
be in the in the cpi now they took that
out because they said okay well houses
are a capital ass asset we're trying to
measure consumer uh price increases but
we still obviously obviously housing is
a big consumer expense so it said okay
we'll we'll come up with a measure that
determines basically what is the
equivalent kind of monthly expense of
being a homeowner
and so they they kind of put that wonky
measurement in there and if you track
home price growth compared to owner's
equivalent rent growth there's a couple
things one is that housing prices grow
faster than owner's equivalent rent so
it's basically a way to
understate inflation in some ways
and two it's a lot smoother
um so it doesn't it doesn't go up and
down as quickly as housing prices do in
some of these big events um and yet you
know so if you look at say the largest
owner of single-family homes in the u.s
is invention homes it's publicly traded
i believe it's a reit structure but it's
publicly traded and so they own like
tens of thousands of single family homes
and they they disclose their rent
increases
and off hand the numbers were something
like 16 percent for for new tenants
and something like seven percent for
renewals and the average was like 11
across their board for rent increases
whereas if you look at rent and cpi it's
nowhere near that um and so it's kind of
coming in with a lag and it's somewhat
understating it so if jack's looking at
or if people square looking at kind of
you know real-time data
they'd probably see you know closer to
the real numbers for for you know some
of the inflation we're seeing rather
than seeing this kind of laggy
managed basket that that slowly catches
up over time but still understates it
got it and then one of the other things
that i'm really really interested in is
as people see the higher and higher
inflation number it feels like people
are getting red pill on a daily basis
and uh they may not even know what
inflation is uh so some see cpi some
just see i went to the store uh while we
were on the show somebody dm'd me a
screenshot of their chick-fil-a order
and it's like 14 right and you know of
course there's sticker shock with some
purchases
how do you
look at changing the portfolio right are
there things that you're tactically
doing as inflation continues to not only
be persistent but actually accelerate in
official numbers or is it no i
positioned myself kind of q3 q4 last
year for inflation and now it's just
playing into exactly how i've been uh
kind of allocated in a portfolio
perspective
so i've not been making many changes
lately because i've been positioned for
this i made a lot more changes last year
or earlier this year where i was kind of
positioning for things
whereas now i've actually been in a
state of not not making very many
changes at all because uh it's just kind
of playing out um but you raised an
important point there of basically
we talked before about differences
between now in the 1940s and one of the
differences is the speed of information
uh and so in the 1940s you didn't have
the internet you you you got like a
newspaper many people weren't even
following the markets obviously uh uh
and so you couldn't sit there and look
up say st louis fed website to get the
exact like you know what is inflation
right now according to the government
you couldn't do things like that and so
when they held bonds they were yielding
zero to two and a half percent for a
decade while inflation was averaging six
percent
you know there are obviously financial
professionals that were aware of that
could and could somewhat quantify that
um but it's not like
people on aggregate could tell you those
numbers uh whereas now with the internet
with twitter with social media um and
memes they can spread information very
quickly
you know
people like just regular regular people
know what they can look up inflation
they can look up bond yields they can
look up their their whatever wage
increase they got over the past year and
they can say wait a second i'm i'm
getting paid less than you know my pay
went up five percent but inflation went
up six point two percent and that that
inflation rate might even be understated
so that's not good or they can look at
you know they can post their pictures of
like their what their thanksgiving
turkey costs this year compared to last
year and then it'll get a you know 10
000 likes and go viral uh and so that
that's a very different dynamic than you
had in 1940s and so that can that can
make it difficult to you know that that
topic is called financial repression
which is where you hold rates below the
inflation rate for prevailing period of
time
and sometimes it's combined with
regulations that force certain pools of
capital to own those crappy assets like
banks or insurance companies or pensions
or other large pools of capital
and financial oppression is easier
when information moves slower
where it's a lot harder to do
when it moves at the speed of light
what questions uh do you guys have hey
lynn thanks for doing this uh so my
question would just be around kind of
what we're seeing in bitcoin i think
most people look at the on-chain metrics
and look really healthy and strong
and combined with the inflation print
and stuff like that i think most people
expect over the next over the next six
plus months we'll see price appreciation
in bitcoin but as we get closer to that
2024 having do you think that uh one i
guess will there be another kind of
crypto winter where we see a big
pullback and two do you think the idea
that uh distribution is getting tighter
right 19 million of the 21 million
bitcoin that will ever be in existence
have already been uh put into existence
do you think that will make that crypto
winner shorter or how do you think about
that
it's a good question and i've i've
thought about this before and i've i've
talked about it to some extent so the i
break into two parts one is the more you
fork of a spike you get like you had in
late 2017 or parts of 2013 2014 the more
you fork that spike is the more likely
you have are to have a crypto winner for
a period of time uh whereas for example
the the high we got in bitcoin back in
what was it april that was less euphoric
and therefore the the the pursuing kind
of you know correction was was less deep
less violent um less long uh and so i
would say part of it depends on on you
know how how
bullish it gets in the first place um
the the deeper part of the question i
think is that the further we go
the having should become less important
and i think this really clear kind of
four-year
price appreciation cycle will probably
become less impactful and you might have
smaller bull markets and smaller bear
markets and kind of the less of this
kind of clear for your thing because as
you point out you know a large
percentage of the coins are already
mined
and the the percentage of of new coins
coming from miners is low compared to
other sources of of supply that exists
in the market from from existing holders
uh whereas before those new coins were a
very significant part of of bitcoin you
know the number of bitcoin that exist uh
and so that should theoretically become
less important we're also seeing
interesting dynamics where
in prior cycles miners were these small
companies often in china they didn't
have great financing they would have to
sell a lot of the coins that they mined
to pay their bills
and so miners were regularly selling to
the market and so we considered this
basically dilution whereas now what
you're seeing is that you know as miners
have
come over to north america and as their
number of companies you know uh whether
it's you know like galaxy or others that
basically improved ways to lend to
minors right so they can they can mine
to them using their asics's collateral
um they can make all sorts of different
types of loans to them and also some of
those companies are publicly traded so
they have much better and cheaper
sources of capital
and so they're actually able to do kind
of the michael saylor playbook where
they they just never sell their bitcoin
they they issue other types of
liabilities whether it's debt or equity
um and that funds their operations and
then they mine bitcoin and some of them
might have to sell a certain percentage
of them it depends on how they want to
do that but the point is they're not
selling like 80 90 of the bitcoin that
they mine and so that you know it's not
even as though that the new bitcoin
supply is really getting to the market
uh there's this kind of this structural
trade change in the way miners operate
and their capital structures this is
even smaller private companies that are
huddling their bitcoin
and again it's partly because they have
lower cost of capital
and because
after long enough time appreciation
obviously miners would
prefer to hold their bitcoin they don't
want to look back and be like man those
miners from 2012 that sold their bitcoin
sucks for them right like they they want
to actually hold their bitcoin and
basically make that a balance sheet
asset in a similar way that michael
saylor does with microstrategy and so i
think that's going to be a big theme so
when you combine those things you know
there's not a lot of new supply
some of the miners are just huddling the
supply they do create
and then you know
just the fact that it's becoming a more
mature asset class it's more widely held
less spiky in terms of price it's
obviously still still a volatile asset
but it's less volatile than it was in
say 2013.
i would expect kind of
bull markets to maybe somewhat less
euphoric and bear markets to be say
shorter or maybe less extreme maybe
instead of a you know 90 drawdown you
have a
50 60 drawdown like you saw this summer
uh so that that'd be my base case but
obviously you have to you have to change
based on on what's happening in the
market
general questions you got yeah lynn
thank you for doing this and i see you
again so the stock market has been
insane it's up s p's up like 25
year-to-date it's at 54 trillion dollars
it was 20 months ago was only like 27
trillion is this sustainable and then if
not what assets can people run to um to
kind of hedge against all this inflation
that's going on
yeah so this rate of growth is generally
not sustainable at least in real terms
uh and so when you look at
obviously valuation metrics were already
kind of high and now they're even higher
now they're approaching records you know
some of them are records other ones are
basically records that are only
surpassed by the dot com bubble whether
you look at price of sales um price
price is sickly adjusted earnings
uh replacement cost market cap to gdp
uh you know there are dividend yields
right there are all sorts of of metrics
to measure valuation
and so it's very hard for him to
continue at this pace now they kind of
go higher i mean they went higher in in
japan for example in the late 80s they
can get to pretty extreme levels um but
it's i wouldn't say a sustainable on a
long term basis
if you look back over periods of
inflation in the past
generally
you know commodities and real estate is
is a better hedge against those sorts of
environments than equities equities have
a somewhat checkered past so obviously
in the 40s they did pretty well but
that's because interest rates were low
and they started with low valuations in
the 70s they did they did about as bad
as bonds did actually so equities were
pretty terrible in the 70s especially
you know growth equities or just overall
market indices um
and so generally commodities and real
estate would would be once and obviously
in this day and age bitcoin would be in
that essentially that commodity bucket
for now whereas is this scarce asset
that you can hold that's that's you know
outside of the you know fiat currency
system that's getting devalued melting
ice cube and so you can you can describe
it as commodities hard assets real
estate with a fixed fixed mortgage right
fixed 30-year mortgage it's a nice thing
to have uh and then assets like bitcoin
lin one of the other things that i spent
a lot of time thinking about is from a
monetary policy standpoint the fed uh
only has so many tools but we also see a
narrative taking over um in the
political realm uh who is basically in
some way uh you could argue that
politicians are having a hand in uh
monetary policy uh and obviously they've
got the fiscal policy uh that they've
more historically uh been able to affect
how do you look at the idea of the
federal reserve or central bank in any
country being independent versus being
heavily influenced by some of the social
programs the the political uh kind of
debates that occur et cetera
so that actually goes back to another
difference in the 40s and 70s and why it
played out like that so
generally the idea of independent
central banking
is that you're never going to have
complete independence but you want to
have some degree of autonomy you don't
want for example the person running the
fed to be the treasury secretary
who can you know juice the economy six
months before an election
um or or you know anything maybe do the
pain right after the election right you
don't want to like do these like
intricate timings uh to to basically
benefit your own party uh and so the
idea of this independent central bank is
that you know they're appointed by by
administration they're confirmed um by
by you know the the whatever governing
body of the country it is um and so
there's some degree of independence and
then they have they have a different
term right so so they basically
um you know they have some latitude to
make their own independent decisions
they're not tied to having that that
group win or lose an election uh in
theory uh and so there's obviously a
spectrum there
and so in the 70s you had a somewhat
independent central bank paul volcker
was basically doing a lot of unpopular
things at the time
um
and he had varying levels of support uh
you know from the from the
administration's throughout his his
tenure um and so that was that was an
example of of you know partially
independent central banking in the 1940s
basically
uh you know independent central banking
goes out the window when you have debt
as a
percentage of gdp over 100
with massive deficits uh because those
deficits have to be monetized uh and so
1940s from 1942 to 1951 there was almost
no central bank independence basically
the treasury you know pretty much took
over the fed
um and they just became the de facto
monetizers of of of deficit spending and
they even did a thing called yield curve
control
where in addition it is holding the
short end of the rates low they actually
hard capped the long end of the yield
curve too so so basically 10-year
treasuries they said we're not going to
let these go over 2.5 percent interest
um and they they had to buy a lot of
them in order to to keep them suppressed
there um that was just a stated policy
uh and so that was an example of
no independence and it was funny because
towards the end of that period that nine
year period the fed
they were trying to break out of that so
i mean you know the war ended in 1945
and the fed's like so we can be
independent right guys and the
treasure's like well not yet we need we
need to do other things too it's kind of
like that meme like the star wars meme
ranik and like says something and then
and then she's like well like
right and he's just like looks at her
that's kind of what happened the
treasure in the fed like they the
treasures wouldn't let go and it was it
wasn't until 1951 that there was enough
pressure to finally kind of get them
separated again um and so
that's essentially what you get into at
the end of a long-term debt cycle where
when debt is super high and say there's
high levels of wealth concentration and
and things like that and and you know
it's it's politically there's no way to
like cut the deficits
that's when you get that merger of of
basically central bank and and monetary
pilot and fiscal policy so you've seen
that in japan for a while now um they
have obviously different circumstances
they've they've traded surplus
uh you know current account surplus they
have you know a lot other things going
for them
that have kind of made that smoother
than we're seeing in other markets um
but in the united states basically the
last time we're in this situation was
back in the 40s and one more example was
during 2020 during the heart of the you
know the the financial crisis that was
happening
there was even like that special purpose
vehicle set up between the treasury and
the fed where the fed could buy
corporate bonds now uh and normally they
can't do that and one of the reasons
they can't do that is because they they
can't buy things that they're subject to
nominal loss on
so they can buy treasuries they can buy
mortgage-backed securities
but they can't buy you know like
a corporate bond because theoretically
the company can default on it and
therefore they would have a nominal loss
so instead
um basically the the fiscal side had to
authorize
um basically a backstop as part of one
of their bills they said okay here's x
number of billions of dollars to cover
any losses that the fed has buying
corporate bonds and then they set up a
special purpose vehicle which was like a
separate balance sheet so the fed didn't
definitely put corporate bonds on its
own balance sheet so it kind of bought
them into this other basket
and then had had that backstop from
treasury in congress um and so that was
an example of a uh you know a closer
unification between them that we that
pretty much that we've seen since the
1940s
got it and when we go looking forward i
i think that uh you've got a very unique
perspective on a lot of kind of what's
happening and what has happened in the
past which i appreciate what are you
looking for as we move forward in terms
of either milestones uh certain
developments certain key decisions like
are there things where you're like okay
i'm going to really pay attention to
this because that will have an outsized
impact on how this unfolds
i would say two areas one is i'm
watching fiscal very closely right
because this is a very fiscal heavy
environment uh fiscal spending is
driving a lot of inflation
and so i'm kind of watching to see what
happens there if you get fiscal gridlock
uh you're more likely to get a period
where
inflation levels off for a period of
time or at least you know with some
delay and so if you go back and look at
those 1940s and 70s charts
it was it wasn't like inflation was a
straight line there were rises and falls
in inflation throughout those periods
and so i would expect the 2020 to be the
same way where
you know you get periods of inflation
and then you get some sort of cool off
period then maybe you get another round
of inflation with there's another fiscal
response and so these these things kind
of come in cycles so i'm kind of paying
attention to the election cycle to some
extent i'm looking for signs of gridlock
i'm looking to to see probabilities of
certain things passing because that
affects my view of inflation nominal gdp
growth things like that
the other thing i'd be looking for
is
if inflation becomes more
self-sustaining in terms of wage that
wage price spiral where where you know
prices go up you have to you know
workers demand higher wages uh to make a
living
and then therefore when their wages go
up their employers have to raise their
prices on a lot of their goods to make
up for that and then that leads to more
wage pressure
and so if that becomes somewhat
self-sustaining then you get inflation
even if even a fiscal stimulus kind of
you know goes dark for a couple years
and so those are probably the two things
i'm watching
in addition i'd pay attention to
the fed's balance sheet so right now
they're planning on tapering their asset
purchases meaning they're still buying
them but they're planning on gradually
slowing down how many they buy over the
next six plus months
and if they
if they're able to get through that and
they eventually to stop increasing their
balance sheet for a period of time
that could be more challenging for
equity markets uh and so those are some
of the things i'm watching i think
pretty closely overall
and when we start to look forward um it
also feels like uh companies are going
to start having to make some decisions
here obviously michael saylor has
outlaid an idea in terms of that
corporate balance sheet as you look
forward at those different events do we
think that corporations will start to
act much more like macro uh traders to
some degree and start having to do
things other than just hold cash and
cash equivalents or do you foresee a
world where
it's hard to kind of move the ship it's
hard to kind of you know uh get them to
turn and change strategies and maybe
they should or maybe they shouldn't but
we we shouldn't expect any sort of
change on a material basis across the
public markets for treasury management
i think it partially depends on one is
how how smart the company is
uh how much
you know basically power the the ceo has
and
how kind of connected that company is
right so an example of micro strategy
you know he he owns the i think the
majority of the voting rights he's
obviously he knows exactly what he wants
to do um he's still he still has a board
to work with but he basically had a lot
of influence over that company and was
able to get on it quick and in a big way
right so all in and early and it paid
off it paid off you know substantially
now if you look at other companies
they can start putting bitcoin on their
balance sheet in a smaller way
and i think it's the closer they go to
being kind of politically connected the
harder it gets so you'd have to ask
yourself why why haven't apple or
facebook or google put a billion into
bitcoin right i mean it'd be trivial for
them they have they have billions and
billions and billions of cash to balance
you some of them have over a hundred
billion dollars why not put one or five
billion into bitcoin um and i think you
know it's hard to say for sure but i
think partially that would spook
congress right so if you start to see
google announce a five billion dollar
bitcoin purchase um they might get
looked at more whereas a smaller company
doing it gets less scrutiny
um and so
i think it partially comes down to how
kind of you know tied they are and then
two just the makeup of the board of
directors uh the makeup of the
shareholder base the ceo right so
if if we keep entering this period the
longer we go with cash and treasury
yields held below the inflation rate
you know the the smarter companies
should increasingly want to to put their
resources into other assets so basically
facebook and google holding hundreds of
you know tens or hundreds of billions of
dollars in in cash equivalents in this
environment is a melting ice cube uh and
it depends on the company so for example
apple they have a lot of cash but they
actually also have a lot of debt they
issue a lot of debt to buy back their
own shares with they kind of they change
their capital structure like that so
they're they're somewhat neutrally
positioned in this inflation environment
because their debts getting inflated
away but also their cash is getting
inflated away whereas a company like
facebook which has like no debt and is
like tons of cash they're just entirely
getting inflated away in this
environment uh and then google's more in
that position as well so really alphabet
it really comes down to the specific
company question the ones you'd want to
look at are ones that just have tons of
cash
that exceeds their debt
and they're just they're just sitting
there getting inflated away and you have
to ask why not put at least some of that
into into bitcoin
i completely agree before i let you go
um
help everyone understand the research
that you do i just dropped the in the
chat uh a link to linaldon.com where you
publish a bunch of research but uh help
everyone just kind of understand your
process and then
if they went ahead they signed up for
the newsletter which i think is
fantastic it's a i don't know if i
should say this but it's the only uh
macro newsletter that i read top to
bottom every single time it comes out so
what what is the process and kind of
what do you spend a lot of time thinking
about from a research perspective
well i appreciate that so i basically
have three types of content really so
one is that i put out public articles um
they just touch on a subject uh
basically goes into detail on something
that and those are meant to be kind of
evergreen like you can go back and read
them two years later and they're still
pretty much relevant then i have those
free newsletters they come out every six
weeks
and they generally talk about something
a little bit more topical they might
include they generally include some
evergreen content in there as well but
it generally ties it more into what's
happening now for the next six months
next year
so those are you know more time stamped
type of pieces
uh and then and then so that's all free
material and then i have a low cost
research service that comes out every
two weeks and i again focus on tactical
stuff more specific investment ideas
things like that and so generally all my
research kind of focuses on that blend
of
macro so what's happening the big
picture right so what's happening with
things like inflation disinflation
growth stagnation
overall asset classes i'm interested in
that's kind of the big picture view and
also what what country markets that
might be interested more than others and
then the micro view is you know what's
happening with technical sentiment
what's happening with
these weird things in the market what's
going on with reverse repos right now
what what investments look interesting
what what is showing signs of maybe
having bottomed and is cheap what is
showing signs of being maybe really
expensive and kind of topping out so
that that's kind of the more tactical
stuff i go into after i already kind of
have a big picture idea in mind
got it you guys got any other questions
no appreciate you coming on lynn i
always learn so much when you do
and thanks for having me anyone who uh
who is not following you on twitter or
subscribe should absolutely go do it so
listen lin thank you so much for doing
this uh i wish that i could say
inflation is over and we're not gonna be
talking about this anymore but i feel
like we will do this many more times
again so i appreciate you taking the
time to come on here
yep thank you all right awesome to see
you later
bye
inflation is not stopping
she gonna be back
big time
we're gonna need her to come back yeah
i don't think this is gonna stop uh but
very clear rational thinking around kind
of what's happening and i love the uh
comparison of the 1940s and 1970s as
again not perfect predictors of what
should happen but a very good kind of
guiding post if you will right
all right here we go
2.5 k likes you know what that means
boys what's that means ladies and
gentlemen one two three press the like
button
how much how much did we give away what
have we done so far
today today or
bitcoin we better give away bitcoin
right now no we gave a lot away a lot
let's give i saw a number the other day
i crawled up on the couch and was uh
let's give away 150 bitcoin 150 yeah
okay you're gonna give it away sure all
right joe's gonna give away 100 this is
special hundred fifty dollars right here
it's just giving away joe's money yeah
in bitcoin it's coming straight out of
my coins actually no i'll probably
translate some usd to bitcoin and i'll
send it translating is for languages
transferring is for example
i don't deal with the fiat banks all
right here we go
one two three smash like button all you
got to do drop your twitter or your
instagram handle joe if you paying you
picking
you guys like that
learn laugh and earn if you paying you
picking yeah yeah it's almost like i
know what i'm doing around here all
right let me see here let me see here
i am going to pick people are saying joe
is special
what's that mean that could be one of
two different ways i'm gonna take it the
good way like you guys uh you guys love
me but who knows what y'all are saying
weirdo
not a weirdo uh all right joe
you saying i smell no we say we smell
your [ __ ]
come on are you picking someone all
right yeah let's go with uh people
hitting joe with bless me bro like joe's
jesus
come on
oh jon found somebody john john tag team
union squad here they go
yeah yeah
dice
why er i see because they said north
carolina represent
come on
down eric
all right before i let everyone go i got
two more things ready so finally he said
he's gonna listen wait hang on so
fly.com go to software.com sign up for
an account get your two thousand dollars
joining us in the diamond again come
join the diamond hits club let's go
sofi.com they got all kinds of things
they also have a credit card that you
can go you can get you earn back rewards
points and then once you get the rewards
points you can convert them out in
crypto uh you can pick from a different
couple different cryptocurrencies you
can leave them as reward points or you
can convert your rewards and pull them
out as crypto so go check out sofi.com
pomp
second thing we've been working
i mean look at that peter schiff lin
alden same day we've been working for
you all
we got a good lineup of guests tomorrow
all i need you guys to do
is subscribe to the channel if you're
watching this right now please please
please please please subscribe to the
channel
we got a bunch of more stuff that we're
going to be working on that we're going
to be bringing out to you guys but
please subscribe to the channel just
yeah
you get to know when we go live you also
know when we post all the videos the
best way you can help us i've had a
bunch of people who are dming me on
twitter over the last couple of days uh
oh actually we're gonna pull up one of
the dm's i got today real quick you guys
ready for this joe and john don't know
about this yeah
yeah i got this i got this dm today this
is why i do this show i don't need to be
doing this [ __ ] but look at this dm hey
there i saw your video yesterday i had
to ask for a raise it was really good i
took your advice and i hit up our
director for some time on his calendar i
just had a half hour conversation with
him and he's going to get with hr and
his vp to start the ball rolling now
outside of our stand your review cycle
let's go
are you guys hype yeah
get paid that's why we do this right
there because literally we can tell you
guys a bunch of different stuff that you
can go you can learn about how you can
get into a better financial position
made my day
congrats
good for you you excited john
so be careful talking to hr though
i don't deal with hr um all right
we didn't even have hr here joe's hr
i appreciate you all so please just make
sure to subscribe the channel watch the
videos that's how you can help watch the
videos consume the content you're doing
more than we could ever ask appreciate
y'all tomorrow's summer friday you know
how it is it's always summer in miami
we'll see you guys tomorrow if you need
thursday if you need something to do
after this the joe pomp show new episode
drop today you could check it out
spotify apple podcast whatever
you want an hour if you want your ears
to bleed
[Music]
you